most know johnny silverhand is a rude
rocker boy but we know there's more to
it than that not just from the game but
past events as well today we're going to
be covering the infamous johnny
silverhand and sum up his life ideals
and interactions with us in game to see
how he evolves as a character in
cyberpunk 2077 but to start we have to
go back to 1988. for those who don't
know cyberpunk as a universe has existed
for quite some time and cyberpunk 2077
is a continuation of the universe think
of a long straight line that all the
past events got us to to the point 2077.
cyberpunk takes the main story elements
from the past pen and paper games
cyberpunk the role-playing game of the
dark future cyberpunk 2020 and cyberpunk
red
all of that leading us to 2077. why is
this relevant because if these games are
part of the canon timeline that 2077 is
continuing then we can use the past
material to understand who johnny
silverhand is and how we got this way
the first chapter this video is going to
be talking about johnny pre-2077
chapter 2 will be during our time in
game and more specifically the story
missions chapter 3 will go over the side
content especially the samurai storyline
and the final chapter being the ending
and how he feels about each one
of course spoiler warning for the past
and present events that occur in
cyberpunk so if you haven't beaten the
game do that and come back but like i
said before to truly understand johnny
we have to go back to 1988 november 16
1988 is the birth of johnny silverhand
or by his real name
robert john lindner at a young age he
enlisted in the military and was drafted
to fight in the second central american
war this war was between america and the
four countries colombia ecuador peru and
venezuela
america kind of won but not really think
of it like a second vietnam war
america withdrew its forces from the
country so you could say it's a loss but
honestly it's unclear is even though
they withdrew forces they still had
active bases in those countries and
eventually the pack that these countries
had would fall and they'd end up
destroying themselves anyway so who
really won this war during the war
however government secrets are leaked
and when the soldiers learned of the
true motives of the war most american
soldiers turned against their commanding
officers and fought back
johnny was one of these soldiers but
thanks to the political and economical
power of the government they convinced
many american people that the deserters
were in the wrong and they should be
hated for betraying their country they
support a protect
during this revolution so to speak
johnny lost his arm which is why he has
a metal one throughout the game after
the war johnny went back to night city
to start a new life he wanted to forget
everything that happened in the wars
that scarred his memory which is why he
changed his name to johnny silverhand
with his new persona he decided he would
expose corporate corruption by starting
a band he started the band
samurai this band was originally started
as a two-man group of johnny and carrie
both wanting to change the world with
music but after a record signing other
members such as nancy
denny and henry would join the group
johnny and carrie were both lead
vocalists and rhythm guitar denny was
the drummer nancy on keyboard and henry
on bass
soon samurai would be the head of the
rocker boy movement and garner loads of
fans in the process
as we know samurai would disband around
2008 though johnny and carrie would do
solo acts in the occasional collab but
denny went to join a new group called
the masterminds henry would work on some
new prototype technology and nancy
went to prison for throwing her abusive
boyfriend out of building window on the
83rd floor
she would later become best isis a news
reporter who we can do missions with in
game while johnny was continuing his
solo career a company known as dbs music
wanted him as part of their brand so
much that they blackmailed him by
threatening to release his real identity
so he decided to release an album where
he exposed himself and his real identity
to the public before the label did and
the reception was overwhelmingly
positive
people were beginning to question the
meaning behind what a deserter actually
was
fast forward to 2013 johnny went on a
walk with his girlfriend alt cunningham
when she got kidnapped by some guards
from arasaka and johnny got stabbed in
the back by a man with mantis blades
with the help of rogue and santiago they
devised a plan to get her back
johnny would play a gig in front of the
front doorstep of arasaka and invite
some fans while the fans are riled up
distracting security rogue thompson
santiago and johnny would sneak into the
tower to find alt
alta was a renowned netrunner and was
working on the soulkiller program the
one that johnny was captured in arasaka
wanted to recreate the program and use
her as a test subject to test its
effectiveness her physical body was
lifeless and now she lives on the net
forever
johnny after this would still talk about
the corruption of the government through
music but this would come to an end in
2023 with the help of rogue morgan
blackhand shayton thomas and spider
murphy them and johnny would have saw
arasaka tower with the intention of
using a mini nuke to blow up the bottom
of the tower having it collapse and end
the fourth corporate war
johnny also used this opportunity to
find alt which is why we see him leave
the group momentarily to go off on his
own
as we know the group was then ambushed
by adam smasher after this engagement
johnny was then presumed dead but we of
course know that he was shoved into
arasaka's soul killer program
his physical body would die and be
disposed of but his consciousness would
live on in the soul killer program
johnny obviously wouldn't have caused
any significant events for a while
considering he's dead
until 2077 thanks to v v and jackie two
mercs who are best friends are sent on a
heist by dexter deshawn to recover an
item known as the relic the relic had
two versions which are explained by
hellman version one is for commercial
use only this was used by wealthy people
to communicate with dead relatives it
only stored personalities and memories
so the person was never actually
self-aware that they were alive again
via the engram
version 2 was the one that we steal
during the heist it was only allowed to
be used by arasaka officials only
this version was just like the previous
one except it had that self-awareness
feature to it that the previous version
lacked
the point was to find a host's body that
was dead and store the person on the
chip
into them just like we see in the
arasaka ending when saburo takes over
his son yuri nobu's body
it looks and sounds just like irinobu
but it's actually saburo inside
notice the key part though dead body
that's why it didn't activate
immediately when jackie nor v had it in
their head it would have happened to
jackie if he didn't take it out before
his death and it activates for us since
v was shot dead by dexter
technically johnny would have taken over
our body but we survived since this
version was experimental and not fully
developed
something went wrong which is what
caused us to also be alive along with
johnny because like i said originally
johnny should have just taken over our
body when we get wheeled home by misty
she gives us two pills
the omega blockers to suppress johnny in
pseudoendotrisine which makes johnny
come out and take us over if we want to
end the pain quickly
afterwards comes our first interaction
with johnny threatening us and calling
us a joy toy we then discover here the
true nature of having two people taking
over
one body where their movements are
mimicked v then passes out takes the
omega blockers and is back to normal
as normal as you can get with a person
in your head johnny wants to take us
over and we're obviously not gonna let
him that's until our talk with takamura
that johnny's now realizing the error of
his ways and now wants to help us as we
can both benefit from this
from here we can either meet rogue or
find judy to figure out the chip problem
we're having this goes into the ton of
different paths with rogue takamura and
the voodoo boy so let's just take this
one at a time and start with evelyn and
the voodoo boys
on the way to clouds johnny talks about
his distaste for judy and he has this
feeling about her the whole time we're
with her throughout her questline even
telling us that we should leave her at
the cottage so we can go
do something else other than this but
we'll talk about that later after clouds
we cough up blood and need to sit down
johnny sits down and talks with us he's
frustrated that this is taking too long
saying we're gonna die before we even
figure out what to do johnny still wants
to enact his plan of destroying arasaka
and since he was given another shot
thanks to being resurrected so to speak
he needs us to help him out johnny talks
about a way we can be saved using alt
soul killer and mikoshi he gives us a
summary which we had already previously
discussed about soul killer and what it
actually does now we just need to find
alt
and mikoshi and we're set this starts
our long journey of discovering its
location
after going through the full clouds
mission and rescuing evelyn we looked
through some brain dances to discover
that the voodoo boys hired her but more
importantly they want all cunningham
this speaks johnny's interest for
obvious reasons so we need to talk to
placeed as he will lead us to brigitte
we discover from brazil that they need
the chip with johnny on it to get to alt
as johnny and all had a close
relationship so the moment johnny enters
the net all will detect us and find us
johnny goes into more detail about alt
he knew that she was in the net and she
tried to actually establish contact with
him before and when she did she told him
to stop
looking for her saying that enough
people died for nothing already so just
let it go
she's talking about how all this time
none of it mattered the amount of albums
the amount of secrets he's exposed
nothing has mattered arasaka is still
growing and will continue to grow
regardless of the damage done to them
that's why he took the nuke to arasaka
we meet with alt and johnny to discuss
with her why we need her to save our
life she would help us but since arasaka
reproduced the code of the program far
from the original work alt has no idea
how to deactivate the program even
though she created it it would be very
simple for her to just go in and do it
herself but they now have a specific
firewall with her literal name on it so
she can't get in
with this though we finally have a plan
for what to do when we enter the
building we just gotta get in first we
exit the chapel and almost black out
again
our relationship as we can see is still
not great at the moment v still has a
lot of hatred towards
johnny vega's more personal talking
about just wanting to be a living legend
but now he can even barely survive
he asks johnny what death feels like and
he says that it was the most real thing
he's ever felt when he was in engram and
mikoshi it kind of felt like a dream but
dying was the last real thing that he's
felt since then the two discussed why
mikoshi was even built in the first
place and how there's a ton of talented
runners trapped in mikoshi thanks to
arasaka
johnny says that out of all the things
that the corpse have done mikoshi is
easily the worst one because you're
denied your right to die and your
identity is swapped without even knowing
it next up is to talk with rogue and
when we do and introduce ourselves she's
already heard a little bit about us
thanks to our heist attempt we need
rogue to track down hellman the creator
of the biochip and since she's one if
not the best fixer in night city she
would obviously be the one person who
knows where he is johnny is actually
surprised that after all this time the
job she went on with johnny and the
bombing that she's now considered the
queen of the afterlife
rogue tells us that hellman is arriving
on an unmarked av in the badlands and
that her contact there will help us her
name is pan am
we go through pan am's mission and help
her get her ride back so she can help us
in return
johnny chuckles at the fact that we're
about to assault the corporate power
station and kidnap a corporate employee
and that sounds like a lot like him back
in 2023. we could see the chip becoming
worse and worse as johnny literally
glitches out of existence for a moment
in the car after a very long quest we
find helman and interrogate him hellman
sadly can't help us because it's that
experimental version of the chip we
talked about johnny and v are actually
starting to agree with something because
their distrust of helmet but hellman
does bring up a good point however
hellman asks whether or not johnny is
influencing our decisions because we
share the same body we quickly shoot
this down at denied and johnny agrees
calling us extremely stubborn we once
again collapse and talk with johnny
afterwards while we've been doing these
missions and exploring night city
johnny's been trying to get a grip on
this whole situation and figure things
out
johnny still thinks we can work together
but v is so confused about it claiming
that the plans make no sense
after prodding him we finally get to
hear why he wants arasaka gone johnny
has seen night city turn into a machine
built on people's crushed dreams run by
the corpos that the megacorps have
controlled people's lives forever and
now they want to go even further and
control people's souls he didn't start a
war to get that patriotic blood pumping
again it's because this war is against a
corrupt system that is now out of
control and if he has to kill people
then he will and if he has to take over
our body to do so then he'll do that too
and honestly he's right these mega
corporations have been terrorizing night
city and most of the united states for
too long
at the flick of a switch someone can
lose their job and be homeless all
because it would benefit the higher ups
we could see the owners of small
businesses being forced to close their
shop or be killed just because the
corporation wants it the common person
can't even fight back against it with
the rant over johnny disappears and we
continue along the only thing left now
is to meet with takabura he wanted to
meet with lady hanukkah's bodyguard oda
so we can have a private discussion but
since that didn't work we have to be a
bit more aggressive and talk during the
parade
johnny just like with hellman also has a
distaste for takamura since he worked
with arasaka before saying that he's a
well-trained dog that needs orders and
that once we use him up we can flatline
him throughout these missions it's here
that johnny learns about adam smasher's
return and johnny wants revenge
the next time he appears is during our
meeting with hanako's proxy as expected
johnny dislikes her a lot as once again
she's corporate but johnny and v do have
some differing opinions on the matter
v is explaining how she just wants to
help but johnny isn't buying it
what did you say clink
[Music]
sound of her attaching her leash outside
we attempt to talk some more and you can
guess what comes next we collapse again
and practically have a seizure johnny
takes control of us for a little bit
just enough to get us to a hotel in
pacifica he takes us here to show us
some old stuff he has stored in the back
inside hidden away are some dog tags
from the central american conflict he
enlisted in
he talks about the time that he realized
that no matter the conflict the corpse
win and the ordinary people lose that's
why he rebelled b and johnny have the
most real hearts of heart in the game so
far as we discovered the tags belonged
to someone he knew who saved his life
and giving him these as a sign of his
promise to us
he wants to be wiped johnny leaves v
lives and everything goes back to normal
but johnny has one last request his
dying wish so to speak which is to kill
smasher and bring rogue with us to do it
this ends the conversation and takes us
to the ending of the game
as i said in the beginning we'll cover
the endings in the final chapter so
before we discuss our final plans let's
talk about the side quests while johnny
does appear in a couple side quests from
time to time which we'll mention later
his biggest screen time comes from his
own personal storyline this is after the
hotel scene where johnny makes a promise
to us about his dying wish for us to
kill smasher with rogue should you
continue this questline we start with
the quest chipping in we arrive at the
afterlife bar and we agree to give
johnny control
johnny now has complete control over us
for real this time as the other times is
more just him trying to get us to safety
when we collapse
this time is different we consensually
gave him full control johnny wastes no
time at all and gets
absolutely hammered he has seven drinks
at afterlife and even more to come
johnny's on his eighth drink and meets a
ripper doc named cassius then travels to
a nearby club for some fun
johnny finishes his drinking spree with
a total of 12 drinks throughout the
night he has some fun partying has a
flashback to the matrix gets knocked out
and ends it all by getting into a car
crash
of course the issue is that we're still
in v's body so v
feels all the effects of johnny's
escapades the positive to this however
is that the stripper he was with had
some info on grayson a guy who worked
with smasher the two could finally
discuss the night and clearly v
is not happy with the state he came back
to after a day or so rogue will have
more information for us in regards to
grayson he's near a shipping yard with
loads of guards grayson and possibly
smashers should be here since after this
mission you can enter smasher's office
so to speak and see his arsenal of
weaponry as a present rogue gives us a
replica samurai jacket with some solid
base armor to it rogan v have some nice
conversation about johnny with some
added small talk while they drive over
after going through the shipping yard we
find grayson but no smasher apparently
smasher is not the head of arasaka's
security so he's going to be stationed
at the main tower we do get to pick up
johnny's malorian gun for the flashbacks
as a permanent item and assuming you've
spared grayson you get the key to the
container which also gets johnny's
porsche as a permanent vehicle but like
i said while the bonus items
from this side mission are cool we still
didn't find smasher johnny tells v to
let rogue know the real truth that this
was all for her he wanted to do this as
to be their last bonning experience now
that he's technically alive again rogue
storms off so we take the car to the
oilfield to find johnny's grave there
isn't much to it just some rubble no
markings no signs nothing
we inscribed our own for johnny and he
asked us what we would write on it if it
was actually a tombstone it's entirely
up to you what you choose as it still
advances the story but assuming you pick
the nicer options he'll say thank you
and says that he hopes to live up to
that this is a huge
change for johnny he's admitting his
mistakes no wisecracks no sarcasm just
pure feelings and reflections
johnny reminisces about his past or
bringing up the same thing alt mentioned
him that so many are dead yet arasaka's
still on top but it was just a waste of
time
v promises that things are going to be
different since there's two of them but
johnny doesn't want to drag us down with
him like he did so many others
him and also the one thing he hasn't
[ __ ] up yet and he doesn't want to
lose what we have with him
saying that most people he thought were
friends wouldn't even want to be in the
same room with him
yet we're with him 24 7 and we don't
hate his guts like the others do
this becomes a huge bond between the two
of them and i mean think about it every
time we mention johnny's name it's
always met with terrorist
[ __ ] loser delusional all these
negative words and yes while in the
beginning we were an [ __ ] to him
as more time passed we opened up and had
more heart-to-heart conversations and
accepted our realities together the two
became legitimate friends not just
because they had no choice since they're
stuck together but because they actually
care for one another it's true real
friendship
v brings up the friends he let down alt
santiago carrie and rogue etc
but mentions that we can still repair
rogue's relationship and johnny brings
up how he was going to ask her to the
movies about 50 years ago
johnny ends with a nice comment to v
before he disappears
absolutely thanks fee of all the heads i
could have popped up
in hella glad it was yours this then
starts the next quest line where we go
on a date with rogue we call rogue and
pick her up if you have johnny's car she
talks a little bit about it but it's
nothing crazy enough to mention
we take rogue to a closed down drive-in
50 years ago this was open but of course
times have changed and it's closed
so through some finesse we get the door
open and turn the projector on and play
some bushido 10. we give johnny control
and he takes the wheel and continues the
date
johnny and broke have some small talk
and catch up things get more provocative
before she backs him and doesn't want to
continue
rogue was trying to suppress the feeling
of change between them and go back 50
years but that's hard after everything
that's happened between them she's mad
for some reason but won't tell johnny
why
and storms off again johnny gives v
control once again and talks about the
knight and says that what is done is
done and
we need to go to north oak and visit
carrie kerry was going through some
personal [ __ ] so he wants to talk about
it with him while also just being able
to see him in general since as we know
their best pals
we discussed this a lot more in the
companions video located in the top
right or at the end of this current
video but we know from carrie's separate
questline that carrie was upset that a
lot of people talked about johnny and
that carrie was just under his shadow
whenever people mentioned samurai it was
always johnny johnny johnny never carry
carrie did have some mainstream success
after samurai but it didn't last too
long and he was always worried people
would view him differently a washed up
rocker boy trying to stay relevant again
we can see that these thoughts still
haunt them constantly as a shard of a
negative review on his album is still in
his mansion to get carrie's attention
johnny takes over and plays a tune that
only he could play perfectly and carey
sees us
he thinks this is all some giant joke
but after being lectured about the chip
and stuff he pistol whips us
so they go upstairs have a couple drinks
reminisce and talk
carrie after some time comes up with the
grand plan to get the band back together
we just need denny henry and nancy
of course johnny agrees and we go find
the other members nancy is at a
maelstrom concert called tinnitus
interestingly enough this quest actually
changes quite a bit depending on your
all food setup mission
if royce is alive then he'll be here as
the head boss if you find brick then
brick's the head boss and if both of
them are dead then a whole new boss
takes over
johnny even brings up how he feels like
he remembers dumb dumb somehow this is
most likely due to v's memories being
shown to jonny and vice versa when the
chip activated back at the landfill
there are some slight other changes to
this mission besides the head boss but
it all ends the same so it's not too
important just some interesting
information
after nancy is henry and denny and the
two are having a dispute as henry
decided to pour cement in denny's pool
we have to choose one or the other for
the concert and it's totally up to the
player who they want to choose
after a day or so everything is all set
up and the concert is ready to begin
the group plays the song alike supreme
the same name is the quest
it seems like the group is having a
blast performing again once it's over
this ends the samurai storyline this
isn't the last time we see johnny of
course as he appears a couple times
throughout the side quest with the
romance characters
he doesn't say too much in these however
as cd projekt red probably wanted them
to more focus on the characters
themselves than on you and johnny but
that doesn't mean he was never there
for a brief summary he doesn't like judy
too much and even offers to
up and leave her at the cabin because he
would do literally anything if it meant
leaving this place
before diving with her he also mentions
how he hates deep dark water as it makes
his palm sweaty just thinking about it
for river in his questline he
occasionally comments on the
investigation regarding information you
would never find but if you do have a
romance with river he is pretty annoyed
with you and it is actually slightly
funny
christ can't believe you're making me
[ __ ] a cop
gonna go plug my ears gouge out my eyes
johnny pops up the least in panam side
quest and the more i think about it i
actually don't think he popped up at
all and even if he did it was more like
riverside quest where there were small
comments about the current mission our
last romance character is carrie units
obviously shows up a lot
talking about the past with carrie and
eve encouraging you to help carrie when
smashing up the boat as he needs to
release the stress
with everything covered though we can
now get to the endings of the game after
our talk with hanukko misty brings us to
the rooftop a place jackie would go when
he needed to make big decisions johnny
lays out our options and gives us time
to make the decision ourselves
if we go in order we have the arasaka
ending first johnny's okay with our
decision but he knows we're gonna regret
it eventually and when we do
he's not gonna be there to help us and
he was right i won't go too in depth
with these endings as i've covered them
in a past video as well cause for right
now we're only focusing on johnny but we
take the omega blockers and johnny
disappears until we arrive inside
mikoshi
johnny says that we're acting like the
murky met at the landfill someone with
their head in the clouds and
absolutely clueless it sounds like he
thinks that we betrayed him but johnny
reassures us that we didn't betray him
we betrayed ourselves
v wants to end things between them on
good terms but as johnny puts it
not sure that's possible anymore johnny
then explains that it's not about
arasaka or the chip it's about the
principle the thing that will show us
the way home the thing that puts us back
together when we're broken our code to
live by and we're going against it
that's the last thing we hear of johnny
before he disappears
not mad or upset just disappointed in us
that we would let our dream go so easily
at the smallest hint of death and give
in to the corporation's help after all
the manipulation and schemes that
they've pulled on people in the past
penamen rogue's ending is roughly the
same so let's cover both their
beginnings then reconvene at the end
inside mikoshi since the beginnings are
different but the conversation at the
end is somewhat the same for panam's
ending he says the same thing about
regretting the decision but also brings
up that their lives are on our hands now
for the beginning of rogues we let
johnny take over
v tells him to take it easy on the body
and johnny thanks v for giving up
control and says that he'll succeed for
the both of them
as we know for both these endings they
ultimately arrive in the net and talk to
one another
at the end alt explains how she managed
to separate the two but v discovers it
doesn't matter as separating johnny
didn't save his life he's still going to
die
the next part may be a little confusing
so let me try to explain if the person
who inhabited the body during the ending
takes it back
nothing crazy happens but if they give
it to the other there is some discourse
if we are v in v's body and we take it
back as v then there is no
argument we just get in the tub and go
back to our body but if we decide no
johnny gets the body johnny argues with
us saying that this wasn't the plan and
we should live up the time we have
for rogue now johnny inhabits the body
in the beginning so if we just give it
back to johnny nothing really happened
since he was the last owner of it
v is upset and mad because it seems like
he was tricked and that he was never
going to live
anyway as opposed to johnny sitting next
to v near the well and panams ending v
doesn't move from the chair he just sits
there knowing that it's all over which
is quite sad to see
if we do the opposite v is extremely mad
at us he says that this was the deal
you're out i'm in this is honestly one
of the most confusing parts of the
ending for me but i've always
interpreted it as this
v wants in as in in the net and johnny
wants out as in out of the net and in
the body cause he punches him while he
leaves and v gets the body
why would v punch johnny after he's
doing exactly what v would want him to
do so i always thought that that was the
way to interpret it regardless any of
these options trigger their respective
endings the only one that matters is
when johnny takes the body at the end as
that is the only ending between these
two that we see him
involved he's now in v's body living a
normal life in some apartment we meet a
kid named steve who we take around with
us
johnny talks about v on occasion
mentioning how this necklace johnny's
wearing belongs to him he plays some
guitar for steve then heads to the
cemetery to drop off the bullet necklace
and leave town
thanks to this decision johnny is wiser
now and learns that even though his
friend is dead he needs to continue
living for him no matter what for the
suicide ending we see johnny and v
have their last heart to heart johnny is
confused why he would do this but v says
it's the least bloody option it's the
only way that both of them are going to
be fully aware of their deaths
v asked john if he's all right with this
decision and he says that while it's not
his first choice he's okay with it the
two exchanged their last words before v
kills himself been nice
yeah with you too johnny
last is the secret ending don't fear the
reaper and the ending part of it is no
different than what we discussed before
but the beginning is drastically
different
johnny comes up with the plan on what to
do and v agrees with the plan saying
it's the least bloody option that he'd
rather die in a blaze of glory we do
hear johnny periodically throughout the
ending but nothing of note just him and
v
throwing out ideas on how to get into
mikoshi all these endings are the last
we hear of johnny which means we've come
to the end of the video
johnny went through such a development
of character throughout this game our
first interaction with him was just
us fighting against him then opening up
more and talking about his feelings at
his grave to our final goodbyes inside
mikoshi
i think cd projekt red did a great job
with johnny as he's such a fantastic
character
i hope you all enjoyed the deep dive of
johnny silverhand if you have any more
videos from me do not hesitate to bring
them up in the comments down below and
let me know in the comments as well what
you thought of johnny did you hate him
the whole time
did you feel bad for him let me know
with that though take care everyone and
hopefully i'll see you in a future video
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you